vous les avez peut-être aperçu
aujourd'hui naviguant sur la loire deux
jeunes aventuriers pirates des fleuves
en manque de liberté originaire du sud
de la france ils se sont lancé le défi
de relier roanne à nantes sur leur
radeau de fortune
une embarcation tout confort ou presque
qui n'a pas manqué d'aiguiser la
curiosité des badauds de passage
reportage de sébastien branger il n'est
pas impossible que ces prochains jours
vous croisiez sur la loire cette drôle
d'embarcation et les pirates à bord se
sont johann et florent à marseille et
pour le premier et un bayonnais pour le
second les trentenaires sont partis de
roanne
il y à un mois et termineront
tranquillement leur périple à nantes on
est un peu coincé donc on est on est à
ces aventuriers de base et on s'est dit
c'est france et un autre dans la tête de
remonter sera de descendre à un fleuve
et on s'est dit en france la loi
les aventuriers attire l'attention leur
voyage est ponctué de rencontres comme
ce matin sur la plage de la ville aux
dames
[Musique]
pourtant on est en l'air et pousser
pousser quoi on va partir et raid
aventure ah bah moi je suis prête à
partir avec pas de problème il m'emmène
où ils veulent
moi je parle aventure je prête comme
vous voulez monsieur mais on a souvent
beaucoup de curieux qui viennent montée
on a embarqué un enfant il ya quelques
kilomètres
ouais c'est sympa de voir bleus
demandé jean cap et atypique
le pôle wilson est enfin en point de
mire un passage compliqué pour les deux
marins mais qu'ils ont réussi un passé
haut la main après nantes
les deux comparses sont bien tenter par
une autre aventure
ce sera rejoindre la mongolie à cheval